this is Mark Billy Billingham he served
in the British SAS for over 17 years has
been responsible for planning and
executing strategic operations across
the world is a certified
counter-terrorism instructor has led
countless hostage rescue missions as
well as much more today he's joining us
to break down even more SAS missions
from across the Call of Duty franchise
it gets chaotic you know weapons at all
other plays people shooting the reality
is of it is it would be slow methodical
we've already got two videos featuring
Billy on the channel including a deep
dive into the clean house Mission from
Modern Warfare 2019 so be sure to
subscribe and check those out and if you
want to see more of Billy Billingham you
can check out the links to all of his
socials as well as where to buy his new
book survive to fight in the description
below right over to Billy
something worse do we have snipers in
position negative sergeant Julie Alum
the public weapons in view that's them
save it to Raven white van multiple
military age males weapons visible
moving to its set
please please get your hands up now get
down on the ground
the build up is really good where
they're sat there you know it's covert
the only thing I'd say in there is when
we're doing the Culver stuff we don't
use we don't call each of a captain
Sergeant Bob John and I'll probably for
to get it over to people playing this
game you kind of wouldn't get that so
you'd be very cold but you go like John
yeah you've got eyes on him you've got
it definitely got Target yeah weapon
scene so everybody knows their weapon
scene this is gonna go this is going
live this is real all right so that was
good that was a great start and then it
went into
uh confronted the Target because he's
gone they're about to lose control of it
so they've had to engage it which is
good so it's got noisy which he did
[Music]
it gets chaotic you know weapons there
all over the place people shooting the
realities of it is it would be slow
methodical the last the only people
would be firing indiscriminate and
Wildlife would be the terrorists the
team going after him would be moving
slow soaking up what they've got firing
and then dodging it until we get to a
point where he could take good aim shots
which goes back to my point I bought a
ball along you wouldn't be fighting
automatic no way especially when there's
crowds and civilians and all the rest of
the stuff so that's a big No-No if a
single pinpoint shots
moving slowly not slowly but
aggressively more controlled but what is
good again you're getting the verbal
communication across people are talking
and shouting so you kind of get a visual
of what's going on although it's Madness
around you never get to that point I
mean I'm not one of them
can you help I'm trying let me see if I
go
it's coming off
I can't get it
what are you doing
okay
it was nice
warm is clear
everybody stay calm they say you can't
we just go up in London the proxy is a
real Target proxies when like somebody's
being held as a bomb used as a human
shield and a bomb that does happen
and the thing there again a bit
unrealistic is once you've located that
you wouldn't go nowhere yeah you'd be
putting your webinar in as well it's
almost like he was a Target and just
making him stay exactly whereas and get
the people in eight or get everybody
else away from it
letting everyone know you've got it
contained and they get the only Sports
of people in there to to deal with that
we save lives are very sergeant
this shouldn't have happened in the
first place sir and then I'll tell you
what is good there is some of the stuff
that does that really happen you know
the frustrations of why we're allowing
this to run so far and there's always a
bigger picture you know which we get
most of it you don't get all of it but
it does sometimes run closer than it
should we should be allowed to gloves
off a little bit earlier and go
just take the bloody gloves off and
fight
so that was good to sit up at the end as
good as the job seems all right we've
done it we've stopped it we've stopped
this there is a bit of collapsible
damage there's always frustrations if
that could have been done better and
that's probably what's highlighted well
there but what is true true as well as
the product picks up is even when it
does go chaotic right when it goes mad
and you're getting friends flowing at
you the suicide bombers there's people
shooting here how come the blogs are
it's really calm you know he's shown to
it he's over there he's got him yep got
it sorted I want it we really is that
calm we don't turn into like they are
endless chickens and running around like
it's kept calm spoken too calm sheltered
aggressively one so you can hear what
you want doing two to get it moving
so there's some good little bits of
realism in there I like that but
don't call me Shirley you've actually
I've heard that so many times over the
net and that's something that the blogs
do in in the worst case it's so nice
because it just calms everybody down
makes everybody laugh so that the um is
good
right it took me a few seconds there to
realize the plane was actually moving I
thought it was grounded but it was up in
the air which is even more Bonkers I
guess an aircraft on the way nightmare
anyway would be you know what what you
would have on well I can't really
imagine that's an iron where that would
really work or what happened
unless you were doing the old Sky
Marshal type thing so he wouldn't get
into that scenario though really around
big big aircraft like that
again is automatic fire imagine that
everything that's special and aircraft
has got to be pinpoint accuracy because
decompression decompressor plane it's
basically going to blow up anyway or
crash probably
yeah the amount of over penetration
although it was look like they were
using we were using the friends were
using nine millimeter which is probably
what you would use on on the aircraft
pistols and mp5s
is that
yeah
we don't have much time now
prepare to breach
what you got to run through a firefight
we're gonna put a shirt on your back
it's Christ
although I didn't say about you I'm
guessing they had one on the back
you reckon oh good
Echo 3-1 primer extraction file we're
down on the roof
I made the initial bit there the coming
along for the helicopter which you know
the mission's Great
sounds realistic the task to go in
Faster up to the roof and then work your
way down that's fine and the place being
on the seats that's that's the mission
that we have done so now we're back into
kind of karma realistic you know we're
going to remember so that's creating the
seeds once you're inside you know it's
it's going to be like this
yeah good it's good scenario I'll tell
you that's very similar to a situation
in Libya with blue
Mountain I think it was ex regiment guys
ambassador's still inside sir he's
trapped okay keep him on the line he
might be our way out of here but the
scenario was good and the graphics are
great from the you know the part where
they moved they've done the ostrich
release then they moved to what they
call a safe house and then all the
opinion that down yeah that's exactly
what it'd be you'd be up on the roof
you'd use your mortars any machine guns
that's that's where you would be seen
automatically you'd probably put kind of
machine guns on the corners and they'd
be swinging arcs of fire across that
Killing Zone you'll be doing exactly as
they did there light them up with the
aluminum from the motor and then use
automatic fire a non-vehicle across the
field
a civilian or a carbon
he's headed our way
no visual
so again that was good that was good and
so you showed the calm side of it which
shows you have commanding control in the
chaos
yeah again I mean I can relate to
somewhat similar to this place
absolutely chaos where you are defending
it becomes the whole whatever it is in
front of you where it's all in planes or
Urban like this it's a Battlefield
all the stuff in the killing house is
down to that pinpoint you know you'll
have an ostrich and a terrorist right
next to each other will you take that
shot should you take that shot and you
practice all the time that's why we
always go for a double tap suit bye-bye
it's it's just it's simultaneous two two
very accurate shots and it's it'll be
ambassador's Ed's there the target is
here so you've just got to get used to
bang bang and instinctive instinctive
instinctive so yeah it's realistic what
you just said there so
foreign
coming coming from a one of these like
mini subs onto Target onto task but
that's that would be probably SPS and
our boat troop doing that
we're clear civilian hostages at your
position watch your fire Roger that team
okay movement's good again Commander
control is good it's methodical
clear we're clear hostages secured in
section two Echo I mean I could get
nitty-bitty about you know the door
explores you stuff and all that but I
won't but this because the idea is right
you do use explosives like that
control
our cities have been secured I repeat
all hostages secured the oil rigs are a
big threat it's a realistic Target and I
guess you know some of the things that
we're doing there using people as uh IDs
is pretty realistic so it looked it
looked great you know but what I really
like about that is all of that was the
command and control it's a lot it's slow
it's it's moving it's realistic and the
fire pal
you know that's because that's what it
would be so that's the first time I've
seen that in any of them really
all right
I mean uh entertaining again in it
um plenty going on
I'd say you've got good good um you see
magazine changes verbal Communications
and call signs being used which don't
really relate to the chaos that's going
on in there and having been the
commander on the London bombings that's
exactly what it was like not
[ __ ] Madness no I mean it's just it's
entertaining you know for me I'm not a
big game sort of playing anywhere
watching that it's it is it grips it's
it it's fun it's good it's uh but I find
I'll lose who's what and what's going on
there's that much going on around you
you know it's it's wild the equipment
and the look of the part it's just it's
of course it's Johnny Rumble come
Apocalypse Now all joining together but
the chaos of it but then the cool
control and in terms of collateral
damage well you know you definitely
break in a a small look with a big
Sledgehammer though but it's uh it's
it's good it's good entertainment
[Applause]
people will even in the face of danger
you know a lot of people just hang
around and watch stood there just
watching what's going on you know when
the London bombers is a great example
moving into in and around London armed
up as we were and just seeing that the
amount of civilians stood around
watching
and I think even more so today you know
it's the only difference is more today
is you'd have a they'd have a camera in
their hands everybody's that stood there
with the bloody mobile phones filming
everything aren't they so I always say
in every battle conflict whatever we do
or been in there's always surreal
moments and they're kind of surreal
moments out there you know when I know
that's all make-believe but you know
when there's anything going on people
are they're out there they're just
chasing that want to be part I've been
watching seeing
visualize it so yeah
you broken
oh good
huge thanks to Billy Billingham for
joining us in this video If you enjoyed
make sure to hit that like button and
subscribe and check out our previous
videos and of course be sure to check
out Billy's new book all the links will
be in the description thank you for
watching
[Music]